à chaque étape de ce dossier et
particulièrement que depuis la situation
c'est fortement durci c'est-à-dire
depuis la toute fin de l'année 2022 les
services de l'État chacun dans leur rôle
et préfet les sous-préfet dans leur
mission respective les forces de l'ordre
tout particulièrement la gendarmerie
départementale l'opérateur désigné pour
gérer le dossier ont été constamment
présent
on consacré énormément de temps et
d'énergie à la gestion de cette affaire
à toutes les étapes il a été rappelé
qu'il s'agissait d'un sujet de la
compétence de l'État porté par l'État
local dans lequel celui-ci s'est
constamment investi
la commune en général assez tranquille
de Saint-Brévin à certes été secoué par
cette affaire mais elle n'a jamais été
laissée seule dans les difficultés comme
comme démontre cette exposé un peu long
mais nécessaire pour mesurer
l'investissement des autorités éthiques